latest episode of icons again it's the
nfl films produced epics produced and
broadcast
60 minute documentary that is soup to
nuts
fantastic about the subject matter at
hand an iconic football player and
jerome bettis getting the icons
treatment this week joining me on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line right now
how are you jb
i am great man thanks for having me on i
appreciate you you got it um before we
get to your episode of icons i want to
jump straight into this uh the sunday
night game where
every steeler under the sun that got
uh inducted this past year into the hall
of fame after two years everybody got
their rings on the field and and gold
jackets all around what was that like
for you that night jerome
you know it's just great to see these
guys uh you know get the credit that
they deserve and you know you know with
the crowd and you know it's that one
last opportunity to
to get that uh the adulation from the
fans and and and that moment uh and just
to see those guys man i was uh i was so
proud to to watch uh
all that happen and it was uh it was
impressive to see yeah but let's let's
let's stop being humble here um because
i'll say it because you're a humble guy
i mean what what was that like for you
like you're a steeler legend you know
what i'm saying like now your your your
playing career is is over as we've known
for a while but now
you're there that's mel blunt and rod
woodson and you know i could go all on
down the line here of like whenever the
steelers get hall of famers together and
you're one of the first calls made
because it can't be held without you
what is that like
for you a kid from detroit jerome perez
come on now you know
it it's um
it is it's special because
it wasn't anything that that i expected
um what do you mean and so what do you
mean like when you're growing up you're
talking about you know i when you play
football you don't expect to go into the
hall of fame you know what i mean and so
i was just
expected to hopefully have a good career
and you know you know make my family
proud do those kind of things
and you know as i got going you know the
the the kind of that inside thing that
you have that is pushing you and driving
you it kind of went into overdrive uh
and so i just you know i wanted to be
the best i could possibly be and that
ultimately resulted um in a hall of fame
career but that wasn't the plan so to to
you know to get that nod and to be uh
standing next to these giants um
for the steeler organization i mean it
was just like wow because i just go back
to you know a young kid from detroit um
that you know was his first year
football was in ninth grade so to go
from there to
you know be standing next to the giants
of the game uh it was uh it was a wild
moment for me yeah and and um you know i
guess that what i just asked was a
question version jerome bettis of what
troy paolo malo said in his speech
in his induction speech this year is
that when steeler players who are in the
hall of fame look at you and said you
could have played for us with us that
that's the ultimate
compliment you know like
you know like somebody somebody like
jack lambert or whomever or bradshaw or
whomever can look at you and go lin swan
all those guys you know you could play
with us like that's that's it right
there that's that's bad
and for me i had that moment when jim
brown
i go into the hall of fame and then you
know they we have that press conference
that saturday at the super bowl
and i get up on the stage and jim brown
is there and i go to to say hello to jim
brown and he says welcome to the family
he says
he said he says
we're just alike you're just like me i'm
just like you and i was thinking like no
i'm not just like
mr brock
no not quite but i it it was him you
know saying that it was just like wow
um for him to say something like that
was was very special and it it it it was
that moment for me like wow i made it
yeah nfl icons is an eight-part
documentary series that is produced by
nfl films i am honored to be
narrating it for epics and jerome
bettis's um piece and his uh his episode
comes up this saturday night at 10
eastern time on epics and we'll get into
that a little bit more let's let's
linger in the present now that night
um
naji harris had his best game as a
steeler i mean they really leaned on him
and he's balancing out this offense
is he as big in person as as he looks on
television
jerome he is he's taller than me he's
you know he's got a good good bill not
as big as me of course
but i mean he is put together and so i
was i was impressed because you know you
don't know what a guy looks like and and
so until you you get up on them and and
i had a charity golf event he came out
to support it um a week about a week and
a half ago and i got to say to him and i
was just like whoa
okay i get it now um
he's he's put together he's tall but he
is he's built uh and he he runs uh with
that passion that energy and you see you
see him i mean he's jumping over guys
he's running over guys he's running
around guys and i was just i'm saying
like this guy has he's got that it and
uh it's just it's just fun to watch
another guy in the early part of his
development uh have
that that thing that you want to see
and with the organization that you know
can utilize his skill set he might be
the most valuable steeler on the team
i'm not going to lie and i know what i'm
saying i understand that that as a
mouthful and that there's tj watt and
there's this and there's that and wat
you know pretty much ended the game in
overtime
so how about this i'll say he's as
valuable as tj watt because he he is
what helps ben not have to wing it 40 50
times a night there's a reason why i
think ben wasn't hit or sacked on sunday
night against the seahawks because here
comes 22 potentially being rolled
downhill or he's an option coming out of
the backfield
uh for the passing game
what do you think jerome rich that was
not too much to say that wasn't i
understand you know tj and and you know
all those guys on defense
but i i would i would dare say
you are correct
because if he is not there
it's a one-dimensional offense and we
have seen that story we know what that
looks like ben is going to get hit 20
times he's not going to make it out the
season and it's going to be a lost
season you bring and naji harris you
bring them in now they become a
multi-dimensional football team run the
football throw the football screen game
uh play action game all these things
start to happen
now all of a sudden you've got a totally
different football team you've got a
different offense but more importantly
like you said you have a different
quarterback you have a guy that can
throw it he can spin it and people just
talk about being all he's washed up ben
can still spin it the problem is he that
doesn't have uh the ability to stretch
to play like he used to with his legs
and
and now that he's getting older that is
star he's starting to lose some of that
so he needs some more protection in the
pocket so if you can get to give him
some protection i.e running game don't
force it not to throw the ball 40 50
times the game
now
you've got a sustainable offense that
can go out week in week out and win
football games with the championship
caliber defense all of a sudden um you
gotta you got an opportunity to to make
something happen what do you think is
going through ben's mind in this
as as he is growing older you know i'll
be honest with you jerome i know you
don't watch
everything that i say and you know even
though you're a friend i still consider
you that um despite not seeing
everything that comes out of my mouth
but um i i said in the first couple
weeks that ben looked washed and and i
you know i never talk in that language
like that i said he looked that way how
do you think he is handling
the growing old part the drag
getting old to use the rolling stones
line you know what he gets it and that's
the one thing ben gets it he understands
it and he understands the criticism you
know he gets all of that he knows that
but he also knows that if you can give
him some help
then he can do some things
a 40 year old guy getting bashed around
and beat up and and hit and hit uh you
know 30 40 times all over the box he's
not gonna be accurate you're gonna want
to get the ball out of the hand he's
playing hot potato with the ball he's
trying to get out of his hand as quick
as possible and sometimes he's going to
the wrong guy and and so but if you
protect him you give him a chance you
allow that that offense to do other
things then all of a sudden you got a
poised quarterback who knows how to win
football games he can still make every
throw
and so i just think
you know if you can take some pressure
off of him then he's he's going to be
much better he's going to respond much
better and physically his body is going
to be much better because i'm going to
tell you what i mean at his age to get
beat around
you know who wants to do that
i don't think anybody does well i mean
in terms of beating up before we get to
your episode of icons uh i'd be remiss
if i didn't ask you about derek henry i
had
uh our buddy marshall faulk on earlier
this week and he said that it's so that
derek henry is it's one of the many
things that he presents as a problem for
other teams is he's impossible to scout
team he like what do you that what are
you gonna do put a defensive end
in that position
on your scout team for your defense to
get kind of ready you know
and i asked derek henry about his
recovery process he mentioned every type
of tub you know except for like a tub of
butter you know hot tub cold dub he's in
every tub possible
what do you make of of his usage and his
remarkable ability to do what he's doing
right now oh boy i i'm just telling you
i am so impressed
uh with what he's been able to do us i
mean it's just like
it takes you back to the old school you
know he's a throwback type of running
back back to the era when when that that
feature back was the guy 25 30 carries a
game that's that's what you were looking
forward to
uh and you said okay it's gonna be black
and blue game put your big boy shorter
pads on you know here it comes you know
where he's gonna be you know it's no
surprise you just gotta stop him right
and the problem is
once he gets ahead of steam going you
can't stop him and
and the biggest problem is once he gets
loose you can't catch him
so now you got a guy you can't tackle
and if he gets loose you can't catch him
so he is i mean he's a legitimate
problem
um in the in the greatest form because i
i'm a fan of running back so i love
watching him work uh because you know
it's coming it's just a matter of time
it's like okay oh he almost hit that one
here it's coming and and you see the
defenders trying to find a way to tackle
him
without hurting themselves in their in
the worst possible way
and you know he's just stiff-arming guys
throwing guys around because everybody's
coming in
with concern of their own health
so that's why it's so fun to see
what a great way to put everyone's
coming in with concern
um what is it like jerome bettis to be
in a huddle in the fourth quarter your
numbers called and you know
that the defense knows you're going to
get it and you know the defense wants no
piece of you
at all what is that feeling like
that's when it's fun that's when it's
fun
because
it's a test of wheels
and that's when you say
i'm better than you
you know what's coming you can't stop it
and
when you're when you're on your game you
can see
the their eyes their faces
everything is telling you
that they are defeated
because they they know they can't stop
it it is the best for running back is
the absolute best feeling to have
uh to know fourth fourth quarter
three minutes to go
you won't touch the ball again we're
going to finish this out um that is fun
to see and we just i just watched it
last night i saw the cleveland browns
with four minutes and 40 seconds to go
kneel on the ball at the end of the game
and that was the end of it and and that
that that is fun for me to watch it's
not the 70 yard touchdown it's that
that that four minute we're just gonna
give it to the running back and you
can't do anything about it i i just love
to see that especially the kid and
ernest johnson making the most of his
opportunity too that's what's great
about football too right there it is
that kid right last night um hey you
know and then let's get to your episode
of icons as i was narrating it and
reading the copy and they're putting it
together and nfl films is gonna sprinkle
their fairy dust on it and so is epics
and it's gonna be awesome you're gonna
love it on saturday night at 10 eastern
time i couldn't have been impressed more
by the fact of how successful you became
despite being a guy from michigan who
told michigan no i'm going to notre dame
that you were able to overcome
that adversity jerome
in your story i was very impressed by
that
how impressed are you by that
i was i was very very happy that i made
the right decision not going to michigan
and being in the in the line the long
laundry list
of uh of running backs who are good but
not great because they didn't get the
opportunity to really
uh stretch out and so i'm very fortunate
that
i turned down amazing blue and decided
to go with those gold helmets that are
so revered uh
and and loved all over the world so were
you were you wearing like air airplane
wings on your shoulders when you were
playing i mean that's not fair how big
you were i was just watching that old
school footage
like those pads those shoulder pads
i mean that was that's not fair yeah
you're being that size coming downhill
like that
and people don't realize i was a true
fullback so i was 250 pounds
and i was you know i was running uh you
know four or five i was i mean i was
coming downhill on people and i was in
the mindset of trying to hit people i
wasn't trying to to like make somebody
miss so back in those college days i had
those big paths on because i was trying
to inflict pain on the linebackers i
wasn't trying to run around them i was
just i was trying to zero in find them
and try to take them out well i think
again but in all seriousness the part of
the story uh that that you know
everybody does know about you um you
know winning the super bowl in your
hometown your whole family being there
and how remarkable that was but it's
just you being true to yourself like i
know who i am i know what i want to do
and i'm going to stick to my guns and
and you had to do that not once you know
obviously to choose your the school that
you wanted to go to
um but also with the rams and then get
you to a spot where you wanted to be and
where they you wanted to to play in this
the position you wanted i think that's
the story jerome for you yeah you're
right you're right i mean
overcoming the adversity of that you
know that
i had to deal with people not believing
that that i could do it right i yeah
he's a you're he's a fullback he's not a
tailback and and and you know it started
okay well it looked good but then we
still think you're a fullback okay look
good we still think you're a fullback
and so i had to consistently
um just kind of dispel that that idea
that i couldn't do it i could do it and
and in the latter part of my career
there were some questions ah we don't
think he's got it anymore
i had to show them that i still had it i
still could do it so at every road at
every turn there was those people that
said hey we don't know if he can do it
we're not sure in high school i was a
tight end and nose guard they moved me
running back and
you know the question was well you know
can he do it and and
when i was getting dr getting recruited
you know everybody wanted me to play
linebacker nobody thought i could play
you know running back so it was a lot of
that for in my entire career but that's
what kind of drove me you know that was
that fuel
that that kept me going uh to show that
you know what i was more than capable of
getting the job done and it i proved to
be right if you were playing now jerome
uh last one for you if you're playing
now and under the new rules would you
have traded in your 36 for number six
would you have gone back to your college
number like somebody
right now actually actually i would not
have because actually my high school
number was 36. i got six because
um
russ grimm
the the great office alignment for
washington redskins and and and offered
the line coach his brother don grimm was
at notre dame and he had number 36 he
was a senior so i couldn't get 36 i
wanted it and so they said well you 36
is taken by senior he you you can't ask
him for his number that's not even uh a
negotiable so
then it was okay well rick meyer had
number three
and i said okay and and
rodney culver who was a running back
from detroit who had who had hosted me
and was my big brother he had five
so i said okay i can't have three then
give me the six and so that's how i
ended up with six
and it wasn't anything i didn't know
about number six but
i said i can't have a three give me the
six so you amassed all those yards
lauren shared those yards and got in the
hall of fame amassing all those yards in
your high school number i never knew
that my high school number yeah and it
was so fitting to finish my career in
detroit at the super me i started that i
mean it all started there and it ended
there and it was it was just the perfect
um ending to uh a a career that
that i didn't think was was even
possible being a bowler from detroit
never
playing football never even knowing
um anything about college football until
i was being recruited by these schools
are you still a snob about you need your
shoes and your own special ball to to
bolt like you were back in the day are
you still a snob are you still a bowling
snob like you cannot you cannot just put
your fingers in any old bowling ball and
you're feeding any old bowling shoes you
got to have your room i mean i'm a
bowler that's not a snob that is a
bowler you know that's like a cyclist
saying oh give me the rental bike and
i'll ride the rental bike no you like
i'm a cyclist i ride i have a my own
bike i like a professional bike i know
what i you know it's it's like okay you
know that's what it is it's like you
not having your own cheer like oh you
know what
i could broadcast into any mic in any
chair at any time jerome
just give him a chair i just need my
mouth that's all i need is my mouth i'll
just bring my mouth
b-y-o-m bring your own mouth that's my
that's my motto
you want your environment to be
what you like right
that's true okay
just any bowling ball i want my ball
cause i know what it's going to do i got
it you're the best jerome bettis i can't
wait for you to see your episode of
icons on epic saturday night 10 eastern
time you take care of yourself bless
your fam thank you the one and only
jerome bettis hall of fame person and
player at your own betis 36 right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here